after the most recent Pokemon go update
it looks like not every trainer is happy
with the changes I'm Dave and welcome to
your walk five kilometres for a stupid
drowsy Newser food Pokemon go develop an
antic Labs has responded to criticism of
an update of the game that removed the
three-step tracking feature and support
for third-party Pokemon locating
services in a post from the official
Pokemon go Facebook page my antics head
the 3-step display which was designed to
give players a vague indication of how
close a specific Pokemon was had to be
removed in order to improve the
underlying design the original feature
although enjoyed by many was all so
confusing and did not meet our
underlying product goals we will keep
you posted as we strive for improve this
feature the update also restricted
access to the Pokemon go API which in
return meant third-party services such
as poker vision sees the function this
proved to be incredibly controversial as
they offered an easy way to track
pokemon in real times we have limited
access by third-party services which
were interfering with our ability to
maintain quality of service for our
users and to bring Pokemon go to users
around the world discussing its ongoing
effort to launch the game in more
territories mantic said it's working
crazy hours to keep the game running as
they continue to launched globally large
number of users has made the rollout of
Pokemon go around the world an
interesting challenge and we aren't done
yet yes Brazil we want to bring the game
to you and many other countries where is
not yet available if you haven't heard
us tweeting much it's because we've been
keeping our heads down working on the
game but we'll do our best going forward
to keep you posted on what's going on so
what do you think about the changes of
Pokemon go let us know in the comments
section or find me on Twitter at
irregular Dave and for all your Pokemon
news make sure you subscribe to gamespot